So Jacob goes back to Israel and he's
terrified even though it's been 14
years.
He thinks maybe his hotheaded brother
hasn't calmed down yet and he has good
reason to think that I would say
so he sends messengers to Isa who then
sets out with 400 men.
And so Jacob is not very happy with this
whole idea.
And he breaks his people into two bands
so that maybe half of them cannot be
killed.
And then he takes from his large flocks
a bunch of animals and a bunch of
servants and he sends them out to meet.
He saw basically to say look I'm I'm a
jerk.
Sorry about the whole birthright thing.
And.
And here some animals and you know maybe
maybe that's the beginnings of of an
apology.
It's something like that.
And so but he's not very convinced that
that's actually going to work.
But he saw who actually turns out to
perhaps have matured in the interim.
Perhaps that's one way of thinking about
it.
Meet Jacob and says that just seeing him
is enough.
But Jacob insists that he takes the gift
and so accepts and which is probably a
wise thing because even if you saw is
ninety five percent convinced that just
seeing his brother is enough there's
probably five percent of them that still
really not all that happy.
And so you have to be careful.
You know when you say that you forgive
someone because there might be a part of
you that really doesn't that really need
something else before you can actually
say OK look fight you know and you don't
want to fool yourself about that because
that 5 percent that hasn't been
completely convinced will find its voice
at some point and then maybe undermine
the whole reconciliation process.
You don't want to think that you're any
better than you are any nicer than you
are it's not helpful.
And so you saw as smart.
I think so while Jacob smart to say no
no like thanks a lot but take the damn
goats.
And Jacob and Esau a smart enough to
accept that and he might do that maybe
to you know
to please Jacob but also I think so that
there really is the possibility of
establishing peace because
hypothetically the gift that's being
offered is of sufficient magnitude to
erase the debt of the loss of the
Birthright.
It's something like that right it's it's
it's it's the payment of the real debt.
And
Jesus said what I mean is that by all
this drove which I met and Jacob said
these are to find grace in the sight of
my lord.
And he so says I have enough brother
Keep thou keep that that thou hast unto
thyself
and Jacob said this is interesting
statement I think no I pray you if I
have now found grace in nice sight take
the present at my hand for therefore I
have seen thy face as though I had seen
the face of God and now was pleased with
me.
And so that's so he's he's taking the.
Honourable judgment of his brother
because it is honorable because he saw
did get betrayed so he has a right to be
standing in judgment and he equates that
judgment with with what would you say
with the highest of virtues it's
appropriate judgment and so he wants to
make complete amends to ease so as if he
saw as a representative of the divine
element of justice and
I guess that's convincing to you so it's
quite a thing to say.
You know that I need to be reconciled to
you because that would simultaneously
reconcile me with God.
It's like it's crucial.
This is between us.
But it's there's a higher principle at
stake that's vital.
And I think that is the case with
betrayal that's very frequently the case
because if you betray someone you really
have violated you've deeply violated
what can only be called a sacred trust.
It's the right terminology for that.
Take it.
I pray the my blessing that is brought
to the because God has dealt graciously
with me and because I have enough and he
urged him and he took it so you know
this story seems to be something like
Well Jacob was
kind of an arrogant crooked deceitful
character maybe over impressed with his
own ability he thought it was pretty
amusing to pull.
A fast trick or two on his brother.
Then he ran off which is not all that
brave.
And then he got walloped a lot and
perhaps learned something.
And then when he came back you know he
was a different person.
And so that's a
that's a reasonable story.
And you know he he has to repent
completely of about what he did before
he can rectify the situation properly
and he's willing to do that.
So that's an interesting idea too
because it's it's it's an early
reflection of the idea that it is if you
do something wrong in the past a that
you can learn from it.
Right.
So that you're actually capable of
learning and b that you can set the.
Balance right in the present.
Those are very optimistic ideas you know
because you might say well once you've
committed some sort of crime that's it
there's no hope for you but that's
pretty rough because the probability
that you've done unethical things at
some point in your life is 100 percent.
And so if there was no way of setting
the balance right after that then
everybody would be doomed.